[Music]
[Applause]
yes happy Monday everybody so there's a
new Marvel movie out and apparently it
sucks I haven't I haven't seen it yet
because as you know I have better things
to
[Music]
do the new flick is courtesy of Disney
who owns the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but the real Marvel is how each movie
they put out is getting worse and worse
the next superhero should be the
Incredible Shrinking box
office cuz her latest offering the
Marvels was the worst opening for a
Marvel movie ever even worse than Iron
Man versus Little
Women oh they got destroyed in that now
in this universe women are as physically
strong as men I'm talking actual women
now not the ones with 5:00 Shadows who
can pee their name in the
snow but today entertainment is now
secondary to diversity and every cast
must be as colorful as a bag of Peanut
M&M's and twice as nutty it's the
universe according to Disney
unfortunately that's the only Universe
where this crap is a hit and it's a
universe that's more and more audience
find as entertaining as counting the
liver spots on President Biden's
thighs so as Hollywood's numbers drop
like Nancy Pelosi's boobs on a hot
day
whoa it's pretty good for 79 they keep
trying to get us to see movies with a
message but are they getting our message
have they finally realized that most of
us would rather be dry shaved with a
cheese grater than spend 25 bucks being
scolded by a virtue signaling cartoon
apparently not because with the Marvel's
Disney has produced a movie so bad it
makes Hunter cocaine boogers look like
art
do we have a clip of the
[Laughter]
movie you know
what well done well well done I mean
technically that is dog yeah but the
reviews for the flick have been brutal
apparently the problems include the
script the acting the casting the plot
aside from that it's a
masterpiece it's so bad the theaters are
making grief counselors available to
viewers after the film film it stars the
ultra woke Brie lson who's never made a
movie you've seen and she stinks so bad
her first name shouldn't be Brie it
should be limberger am I
right some say she's a piece of ass if
that piece happens to be her head a
sexist would
say but that's beside the point really
because she considers herself to be a
gender activist which to the woke means
all men are awful unless of course they
were carrying a person at a Bud Light
apparently her superpower is making
Talent invisible as far as the script
and the rest of the cast who really
cares Marvel focuses on good movie
making the way the view focuses on
cutting
carbs the the woke idea of making all
the superheroes a group of fully diverse
females beating people up as if they're
guys was based on the assumption that
there is an audience for that
well maybe if they're the US Women's
Soccer
Team speaking of Megan rapino played the
final game of her pro career on Saturday
it ended with her on the sidelines with
an injury in the postgame presser she
decided who was to blame and of course
it wasn't her I mean you know I'm not a
religious person or anything and if
there was a god like this is proof that
there isn't cuz this up um so yeah it
just it's up you guys like six minutes
in eat my achilles I mean what the oh so
her injury is proof there's no God I
would argue the
contrary
yeah an injury during her championship
game is proed positive that God is alive
and well and has a kick-ass sense of
humor you go God but this wokeism in a
nutshell Megan got far on her woke
credentials but when that ran out what
are you left with blame once everything
is Stripped Away there's no Grace or
humility just a jerk blaming God or no
God it's the Yoke of being woke you
expect the world owes you something and
you in turn owe no gratitude but when
the woke well welfare wears off all
that's left is an insipid sermon and
that's movies today the problem is the
audience these producers and directors
thinks exist it doesn't that's cuz the
audience doesn't think like your average
Hollywood producer they aren't cowards
like them audience want a good movie not
phony virtue signaling from a bunch of
elitist PC trying to appeal to
a select group of outraged activists you
want proof it's in the numbers has
anyone noticed that women flocked to see
Barbie but not the Marvels Barbie made a
billion dollars acknowledging that women
would go see a movie about a
doll
a doll they went to see a movie about a
doll that's cuz whoever made it must
have actually had a childhood and
recognize that biology dictates
preferences and that most girls left
alone will play with dolls well some
guys too but those dolls are made in
Japan and need to be
[Laughter]
inflated I don't speak for myself but
while girls played Barbie boys played
army or superhero sure Barbie mentioned
patriarchy a few times but that was so
the producers could check the woke box
but women flocked to it and they loved
it even if the inspiration was a
character made out of more plastic than
your average
Kardashian so the Marvels is the biggest
bomb yet in Disney loses Millions
pretending women would pay to see it
it's the Cinematic equivalent of a Brian
killme
book nobody's buying it but as it turns
out thank God women and men aren't
attracted to a movie with a message that
has no creative or artistic value
propaganda is like porn you know it when
you see it so as long as Hollywood puts
woke before work or a decent script with
good dialogue a solid plot memorable
characters we're just going to skip it
but lucky for all of us there are more
pleasurable ways to spend your day like
a root canal an IRS audit and even
tonight's
show let's welcome tonight's
guests if you serve her gluten B haer
toon host of Kennedy Saves the World
podcast
Kennedy he's like a membership to Planet
Fitness impossible to cancel actor and
standup comedian Tyler
fiser she's thinner than the plot to
Fast and Furious nine New York Times
best-selling author and Fox new
contributor cat tip I don't get
it and he picks his teeth with the
Eiffel Tower New York Times bestselling
author comedian and former NWA world
champion
Tyrus Kennedy you're a female what yes I
know it's true and you're you know
you're Savvy you know pop culture you
like entertainment you have daughters I
believe I'm not going to touch you where
your bathing suit covers yes my point is
you were in their target demo yes and I
love Marvel movies I always have and
Marvel has made some of my favorite
movies over the last 15 years uh there
and it used to be that they would put
something out and you know the the
Marvel creative Universe was something
that had the most intricate architecture
and they were so smart about how they
developed characters and spin-offs and
put the pieces together but
unfortunately and this must be a mandate
from Disney they have lost the plot and
it's really it's sad because it used to
be you could see an ad for a Marvel
movie out of the corner of your eye and
you'd be like yes Deadpool uh this guy
is damaged but really interesting and
awesome and that was a smart funny movie
but this like I I caught a glimpse of I
was like I don't know what this is about
it's to your point it's so expensive to
go to movies anymore why would you waste
your time and money seeing this when the
dialogue is completely predictable and
you don't care about the character mhm
that's so true you know Tyler I didn't
see the movie but that never stops me
from talking about it sure really
doesn't um I think you're the expert
yeah I'm an expert at nothing that I
actually do research on but you know
what Kennedy makes a good point that
those superhero movies are generally
kind of funny there's a lot of teasing
it seems to me that there's no there's
none of that in this it's more about
teaching you something it's all a big
Ted talk you know yeah just watch a TED
talk instead of a movie it's all it's
all meaningless virtue signaling that's
all it is they want to show you know
what they stand for and usually the
woman at the end es up and might fall in
love but this time she just you know
they hate the guys and that's it yeah
and and I think that that reflects the
dating culture is women want they want
to be like their Heroes so I mean my ex
her superpower was emasculating me in
public and I think you know it's going
around it's going around going around
yeah did you see Barbie no uh no but I I
uh I likeed the Ryan goling face so I I
watched all Ryan Gosling scenes I
realized he just looks like he's not a
good actor he just looks like he's
smelling a fart every scene he does that
face it's just
like that's true that's all he does that
acting that's not acting yeah and I
could see it even with your beard you
could see it through my beard I saw it
through your beard but more short
characters no one cares about diversity
about height right Greg because we
discovered Tyler is actually shorter
than me this is the first time in in the
history of I can verify that I saw it
they stood back back in the green room
that's why I'm here of course diversity
higher yes I can Lord over you he can
get a hold of Emanuel Lewis yes is he
alive yes okay good it's the other one
that's dead Coleman God Rest
his cat um uh you loved Barbie I did is
it cuz you're a girl
probably would you like this movie would
you go to this movie I don't go to the
Marvel movies I think I I live too close
to ComicCon yes I just see all that and
I'm like no not for me no so probably
not but I don't really go to most movies
Barbies was the last one I went to MH I
want to talk about Megan rap you know if
that's okay absolutely I dis I I
disagree with you I think she was joking
oh I think she was yeah she was joking
and she was trying to use humor to make
herself feel better about truly a tough
situation she was like this is my last
career and you know and then it's over
like that I think that she probably
wouldn't be that nice to me no she
wouldn't but if I stopped being nice to
people just cuz they would hate me or
did hate me a lot of my relationships
would have been a lot
shorter well that that's a lesson to be
learned that I didn't see coming you
know Tyrus tell me about your feelings
about Marvel you are an expert at these
movies yeah well I don't know if I'm an
expert at them I just it's they're all
the same all these stories that you you
always kind of weave your monologues
with a common theme and it's in this one
it's it's how woke just don't work mhm
and uh you know what and it's funny
because the the woke and we were and and
Cat proves my point cat is puts herself
above it and says well she was what she
said was in poor taste but it was
probably a joke we don't get that if cat
makes a joke then they want her to
apologize the next day on TV or never
work again because you made a joke that
someone might not like she's making
jokes that has zero sense of humor
absolutely she terrible joke teller she
was mad she was upset and she wanted to
blame everyone but here's the thing it
was her wokeness that allowed her soccer
career to keep going there was a young
woman somewhere who didn't get to be on
the field that night because they were
too scared to cut her they tried to cut
her before and she went to the media and
made threats and all this other kind of
stuff and then lo and behold they bend
the knee to the woke the difference is
people aren't bending the knee at the
box office they don't want the woke
story no one has ever wanted the woke
story we've been tricked into thinking
they had these huge numbers because they
shadowbanned and attacked on social
media but whenever they have to step out
that fake world of feelings in the world
war no one has time for that yeah like
Marvel used to tell good movies when
they brought in directors and producers
who grew up who played who lived and you
sign like oh man that's great that's a
great movie then I think it was Thor
Thor was like everyone loved Thor and
then all of a sudden Thor became the
wokest movie of all time and they just
walked away from it people are walking
away from W cuz they don't live that way
they don't think that way and they don't
want their kids that way and I took my
daughters to see Barbie did I love it no
they loved it good enough for me so just
like when they have to watch a Godzilla
movie with me they love the whisper it's
a costume dad you know what it's real to
me
so you know I have a great idea they
should make a woke version of dirty hary
wouldn't that be amazing no it would not
it would be horrible I would so see that
just to see them ruin no you would not
you would sit there and rip your face
off crying why did I say this why not
dirty Harry and Sheriff bark from
Blazing Saddles in a movie together that
would be a great buddy cop movie there
you go all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else